la culture se décentralise avec à metz
en projet un futur centre pompidou le
chantier sera achevé en 2008 dans
l'antenne de ce musée parisien
plus petit que l'original de nombreuses
oeuvres du centre beaubourg seront
exposés christine bost jean-pierre
testeurs metz capitale de la lorraine sa
cathédrale ses fortifications et bientôt
son centre pompidou antenne
décentralisée de beaubourg le projet
messin qui verra le jour en 2008 fait
l'objet d'une exposition en attendant le
premier coup de pelle mais déjà les
références sont prestigieuses
c'est plutôt un peu à l'image mais en
mieux à mon avis parce que guggenheim de
new york a fait à bilbao et c'est dans
le concept un peu la même chose
également car bilbao a mis un bâtiment
révolutionnaire qui est le contenant et
qui attire autant que le contenu et
c'est vrai que le bâtiment dont la
toiture est inspiré d'un chapeau chinois
constitue une prouesse technique et
surtout représente un pari architectural
audacieux
enfin bon sens moderne ça me paraît tout
à fait rien est fait dans l'esprit de
des univers contemporain trois galeries
superposées dix mille mètres carrés
d'exposition permettront de diffuser à
un public européen
les 58 l'oeuvre stockés à beaubourg la
plus importante collection d'art moderne
en europe